well thanks for joining us on good day
las vegas and we begin in california
where wildfires are forcing
thousands of people to evacuate their
homes
the largest fire in the state has just
destroyed a small town
bradley blackburn has the latest
[Applause]
the dixie fire is raging out of control
in northern california
40 mile per hour winds sent white hot
flames shooting up trees
the fire burning out vehicles and homes
as firefighters try to stop
it last night it tore through downtown
greenville leaving apocalyptic scenes in
every direction
an entire community completely wiped out
you need to make sure that you're mining
those mandatory evacuations you need to
get out
thousands of people in the area are
under evacuation orders as the
three-week-old fire continues to spread
all of a sudden the sheriff showed up
and they were like get out get out now
denise clark lost her home in the nearby
river fire
her dog and everything she has now in
her car
as soon as we left we saw fire awful
everywhere i mean we literally pretty
much drove through it
hot dry conditions are fueling the
flames and challenging firefighters
across the west
crews using helicopters and creating
fire breaks
to save what they can evacuee dr glenn
bonnie's
thanks them it's truly amazing to watch
them work with the helicopters and
the bore bombers and everything it's
amazing 20 thousand firefighters are now
battling dozens of wildfires in 13
states it's on track to be the worst
fire season
ever 580 thousand acres have
burned put that in perspective uh last
year was about
260 000 acres so more than double the
acres
burned so far year to date and uh and
we're just
you know we're getting started a
dangerous situation that is
only getting worse bradley blackburn cbs
news